Hey Furby lemon-lime man you're the man
then what's your name I'm here happy at
what I've just met
I've been waiting to meet you man
you got sure how many uncle if ya add me
now you got five
I'd been using their trainer you guys
use your body man you don't have to be a
bodybuilder like this beast over here
use your body use it or lose it
[Music]
my boy right here my buddy dummy right
here never moves you come hit on him as
much as you want
slapping reminds me of the first my life
right here I just take it never moved
but I look good
wouldn't read just a damn dummy boom
don't be that dude
[Music]
this is the freeloaders right here hey
come here freeloader what you doing you
want to do these you do some don't show
anything grab my hand
nice way to cheat your way out of an
exercise I bring my kids down here to
Bobby's in time he goes for it every
time he's a trainer he gets derailed by
the kids
everybody's got their little shortcuts
and their scams and life don't kid
yourself oh my god that looks good oh
yeah that looks good deeper deeper let's
go
give them to me let's go give them to me
make it hurt
come on keep that posture straight so I
let you come down here and play with me
so we have more time together right
while I work out tell me if the camera
what you need to know about money yeah
what's the most important
that stuff dude that was swear I was
gonna pass out three times all right
hello how you doing buddy good man
yeah please see right here you you can
keep that in okay
wait out here
when I was a kid when I was growing up
the guy that the guy that knew how to
take care of his environment was my dad
I was eight years old and then this dude
this dude controlled everything in this
environment
and he left early for work he came home
late took care of his family and you
knew he never gave anybody a lecture
about what to do he just let he was a
good example
and
[Music]
and he had the money and he made the
money we were middle club middle-class
families so we were like little red
brick house white brick actually white
brick house about 1,400 square feet
seven people lived in it and my dad I
could tell my dad was trying to get
somewhere he was trying to move us up he
was trying and he wasn't trying to brag
he was trying to take care of
and so I was watching that right and I
watch where this guy he he's the one
that made the decision where we went how
long we stayed and I started associating
that the moneymaker makes the rules this
is what Elena was talking about you know
there's the money I make the rules
around the money around other things
Elena makes the rules so you got to know
what you're good at what your job is and
what your role is my dad and my mom knew
their roles problem with that is when my
dad died suddenly at 52 years old my mom
was left to do something she didn't she
didn't have it she was not skilled up to
do
and and I was 10 and I wasn't I didn't
know how to help my mom
and my dad left a little bit of
insurance money from the from the life
insurance or the death insurance better
better it's really called death
insurance just can't sell it if they
call it that and my mom didn't know how
long that money would last so
immediately after my dad died when my
what mom should have been in grief she
would win immediately into massive fear
and I could see it I could sense it as a
ten year old my mom was in fear every
day clipping coupons saving money you
know turn the lights off eat all your
food it was constant messages go across
town to get gas like everything can't
buy strawberries today you know there'll
be there'll be 20 cents cheaper tomorrow
everything was about
fear
and so I I couldn't do anything about it
or didn't think I could do anything
about it and I just kept telling myself
one day one day I'ma be in a position to
change this and I think that really
drives me today delight take care of
people not be in that situation again
I am Elena Cardone I am married to Grant
Cardone this fourth of July will be 14
years that we've been together for 15
and a half grant works this hard and
even more so every single day holidays
weekends there there really is never a
break and I believe just from observing
him in his life his journey from when he
began with such a immense struggle from
what he overcame and I think with his
father dying when he was 10 years old he
was looking for someone to take care of
him or just looking for help he was
actually looking for that uncle figure
in his life and no one came and no one
showed up to help so now in his latter
years after he sort of proven himself
and worked so hard and has such an
immense wealth of knowledge that he can
that he can give to others I think his
his main drive in his push is to help
other people I think he's living out
that youth of not being there of not
having someone there for him that now he
wants to be their father so I think the
world is really the beneficiary of that
yeah man I had to get over drugs went to
treatment center spent 28 days in a
treatment center when I was 25 my mom my
brother my sister all gave up on me
like they're like enough that's how bad
trouble obviously I was using was using
drugs every 45 minutes I wasn't using
drug once or twice a day I was using
once or twice an hour whatever you're
not going to do the business being
probably
period so I had to clean up I had to
clean up my deal man 28 days I got 28
days first 28 days of my life in seven
years that I didn't use drugs so I was
like [ __ ] man what am I gonna do now my
fear what using drugs me my feelings
what am I gonna do with all my time so
when you see me run right now I'm
running from one thing to the next thing
I'm trying to stay busy cuz as long as I
stay busy I don't get in trouble by the
way I'm the guy that couldn't pay his
rent $275 a month in rent
ah these are this is still this deals 38
million dollars that's the same deal
this deal right here 80 87 million five
hundred thousand dollars and we don't
think we're gonna get it did you see
Chris's response to this yeah the five
hundred grand yeah this deals thirty
thirty forty two million dollars it's
called the Atlantic deal right I just
got I just got awarded this deal ninety
two point five million dollars 31 acres
of land
well this cost in Toronto did cost one
hundred two hundred three hundred
million dollars you can't buy bottom
line it's got a three or four million
dollar swimming pool four hundred
thousand dollar theater like this thing
is just sick so I'll buy this close on
the deal and then it generates in year
one it should generate four million
dollars by the Ritz and it cost about
two million bucks to operate so it'll
make about two million dollars in gold
we just don't get access to this data
nobody tells you to college hey man this
is possible for anyone I'm not some
special guy trust me anybody can do this
stuff how do you get there is it even a
goal is it a dream you know my buddy
Evan Carmichael talks about dream
believe yep but dream what and believe
what believe you pay your bills or
believe you can one day write a check
for sixty million bucks what do you
believe what are you gonna dream of like
literary I think people's dreams are one
of the things holding them back because
they don't know how to dream I don't
know how big the dream
this is doable for any person I don't
care who you are anybody could do this
deal anybody could do that deal I know
the guys they don't private jet
then they're smarter than anybody else
they're not smaller they don't work
probably don't even work that you harder
but they did they did think bigger and
they get in the end and you can't you
can't catch whales in in a in a bowl
goldfish bubble so you got to be in the
right in the right stream traffic that
was the problem for me I just didn't I'm
selling clothes when I'm 16 years old
I'm making a 6% on a on a tie that's 20
bucks so I make a dollar 20 when I sell
out time and it's kind of hard to be
excited go to McDonald's little
difficult to be excited you know why cuz
I wasn't thinking about owning eight
hundred McDonald's franchises and I
could fly around my family like this and
I could spend time with my the purpose
of a plane is not to show up nobody buys
a plane to show off they buy a
Lamborghini to show up they buy a plane
to take their family everywhere with
them and have the kids homeschool okay
my kids are learning Chinese right now
so that we can go to China and live in
China and make relationships there
they're learning Spanish so you go all
through sucks one of the largest
continents on this planet South America
we can go there and make connections and
have friends in Brazil Colombia
Venezuela Argentina people tell me don't
go to Venezuela then if you don't want
to go there I definitely want to go
there there's got to be something great
there so this is what this is what I
wasn't told as a kid and I'm gonna be in
town all next week before connecting
with you pleasing colorful II then see
if you can see thinkin
you wanna you wanna do it you do it hey
Matt how are you
good good good
hey you you called me about the the
apartment complex here in South Florida
good do you know who does this why don't
you know that why don't you know so who
Emma dude that's an amateur move dude
you sound good on the phone - you sound
good on the phone you got a good
presentation
that's it amateur move bro you don't
know who I'm caught Who I am did you
make in so many calls and you not keep
any records you drive and do yeah once
you get a driver take you take your
seatbelt off right now they meet me I
want to hear you seatbelt take your
seatbelt off I want to hear the timer no
I can't I don't think you're driving
take your seatbelt off oh I want to hear
the time dude I want to hear the term
you got it okay
all right well you're not a liar yes you
did better keeping notes okay hey
there's a great car down you called
about uh you said you had a buyer for a
piece of property you want you work at
Marcus in Millett at
oh okay so do you know who I am now
I do all right yeah so yeah so what what
you said you had a buyer hmm that's not
true
based on your answer right there okay
yeah if you had a buyer you'd be like
yeah I do grant I have a bar full okay
come what's the offer for the property a
property for sale in Tennessee 823 units
okay yeah
thanks bro Thanks good try meadow you
can't do that you can't do that at this
level man so what he did is he went to a
course yeah Dave Lindell program or
somebody scores they print out the list
with your name on their property yeah
can't do that dude no you got to know
what the guy's got I mean you got to put
together the freakin can't sound like a
stupid ass just say hey there's run
secos phone dude this is right seconds
gonna help you yeah who's this
Oh Matt how you doing yeah you know what
you just you just pulled my phone yeah
he was he was just calling back you left
me a message
yeah you know what we got your message
it's actually it was it's on the market
with with some brokers up there so if
you if you want to make an offer you can
just reach out to them sound good yeah
yeah you're awesome man thank you so
much okay
skin the deal man skin a deal dawg yeah
we do we got we got four thousand units
for sale
I got 4,500 units for sale dude but you
got it you got to know what you do don't
make that call without knowing who the
hell you're talking to cuz you couldn't
run into the guy yeah no but I mean you
don't even know what it is bro you you
know you go to the carnival and you and
you freaking shoot you know those little
ducks in the pond that you can't play
what a God has got you can't play on a
90 million dollar deal and ruin first
impression was awesome the last
impression was terrible I'm just saying
like I don't know how you how long you
been playing the game but you know you
don't want to keep making this mistake I
would know who the hell I'm calling what
they don't like it I would know I
wouldn't be just like running down the
street like goddamn Isis terrorists yeah
threatening to blow something up like
like you got to be a little more
precision I like I like the attitude the
pitch was great the opening pitch was
great but like once you get the guy on
the deal dude you got to be willing you
got to know how to tap him out and
that's where I got that's where it got
sloppy I'm just trying to help you so
look we got I got I got 5,000 units I'm
going to 10,000 I got I got we got 3,000
units in Florida we are always selling
our product then
and so just you know note no stork start
shopping the guys that own [ __ ] and know
what they own and then and then when
you're done trying that deal come work
with me yeah okay I don't buy anything
in California so stay in touch with Ryan
you got his number if you got we're
we're an acquisition but we're trying to
buy stuff not sell stuff so if if if you
got something you want it's got a
thousand units that you run across you
get control of and you got a listing on
what works today anywhere in the
southeast
thanks thanks brother believe nation
thanks for joining me today as I walked
through how I start my day I'm not
finished
hopefully you're not finished with your
day we've done about nine hours right
now and I'll go till 9:00 tonight so
I'll do a 15 hour day today I know you
can do it works never killed anyone and
shorted me crying for Evan Carmichael
because I know he likes that he likes me
big crocodile tears I mean if I keep my
kids we're here you can probably get it
from me
because I'll do anything for those guys
but look go out go out hopefully that
you find inspiration in this not
resentment don't get confused or lost
with all the stuff and the junk and the
planes it's just about work and how big
can you dream and how much are you
willing to do for your family to provide
them maybe with a lifestyle and a
freedom and choices that you didn't have
[Music]
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that we believe that
people with passion can not one drop of
my self-worth depends on your it's
supposed to mean if you guys want more
grant cardone checked at the top 50
rules video that I did on him it's right
there next to me I think you're gonna
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there dude you don't get
attention today you have absolutely zero
chance of being successful money follows
attention